salut à tous aujourd'hui je vous parlais
de la nintendo switch j'en ai parlé de
ça il ya quelques temps oui oh [ __ ] ah
ouais merde
en fin de compte j'ai un moniteur si tu
veux qu'ils aient juste devant et qui me
permet dans la tronche
regarde ça c'est mon moniteur j'avais
pas vu que j'avais cheveux comme ça
merde
bon on va remédier à tout ça 1 2 3 donc
voilà ça va mieux comme ça quand même un
peu plus clean donc aujourd'hui on va
parler de la nintendo switch airlines
thaï de switch j'en ai déjà parlé il ya
quelques temps sur une première vidéo
qui a très bien marché d'ailleurs je
tiens à vous remercier et or marquettois
de l'avoir regardé si tu l'as vu et puis
à tous ceux qui ont commenté il ya
énormément de commentaires c'est la
vidéo
au jour d'aujourd'hui la plus vue sur
match elle a pris 30 mai vue donc je
suis très content merci beaucoup des
grands pouces bleus pour vous merci
d'avoir regardé et puis merci d'avoir
beaucoup commenté parce que c'est une
vidéo qui a créé vraiment le débat et je
trouve ça vraiment intéressant en ce
sens parce que il ya vraiment des gens
qui sont plutôt pour la nintendo sur les
envois la série super console avec cette
console on va pouvoir faire plein de
choses qui ont à mon sens compris le
côté de la portabilité et tout l'intérêt
qu'ils avec cette console et puis on pas
qu en face à des gens qui n'aiment pas
trop cette console ce qui peut aussi se
concevoir à l'époque où tu allais ps4
aux égouts talent et xbox qui cartonne
la des consoles surpuissante
on n'a pas forcément les mêmes attentes
qu'on soit sur une plateforme sur une
console ou sur l'autre donc ça peut
complètement se comprendre qui est je
dirais deux types de grands types de
gamer qui s'affrontent sauf que la
nintendo switch est sorti il ya quelques
jours et qu'elle n'a pu être vraiment
essayé et testé correctement c'était pas
uniquement sur la journée de
présentation de nintendo on a pu
l'essayer pendant quelques heures
sans forcément se rend compte là les
vrais gamers ce qu'ils ont aimé la avant
tout le monde avant le 3 mars ont pu
l'essayer directement chez eux dans de
bonnes conditions
testé un zelda brief the wild dans de
bonnes conditions want to switch et puis
les différents jeux qui ont été achetés
donc aujourd'hui on peut se faire un
avis qui est beaucoup plus complet et
qui est beaucoup plus claire la console
la quête mallet dans les conditions du
réel directement chez soi au bureau
toujours est il que voilà aujourd'hui on
avoir des arguments peu plus concret
pour pouvoir en parler alors les gens
qui sont contre ne l'ont pas essayée
donc on n'aura pas forcément les avis je
dirais de ces personnes là tout de suite
en tout cas
par contre ceux qui étaient hyper fade
et qui l'ont précommandé l'ont reçu les
tout premiers je dirais youtuber les
médias les premiers médias l'ont reçu et
on peut effectivement parler
donc je pouvais le faire si tu veux moi
une énième vidéo je dirais de unboxing à
tester la console ya donné mon avis mais
au final ça serait un avis de plus et
puis je pense que ça n'a pas réellement
d'intérêt
j'ai déjà tout dit ce que je pensais
dans la première vidéo donc au final
j'ai décidé de prendre les choses
autrement
la première chose que j'ai fait j'ai
compilé une playlist avec plein d'avis
différents
il ya du hem boxing il ya des avis et
des tests des choses qui sont récents
par rapport à la sortie la console donc
voilà tous des choses qui sont
d'actualité et que je t'invite à aller
voir directement dans cette playlist là
tout est clair là dedans il ya plein
d'infos d'ailleurs si tu vois des vidéos
racheté tu peux me le dire je dérape
choix dans la playlist avec le plus
grand des plaisirs
moi j'ai pris les choses autrement c'est
à dire je me suis dit ce faire une vidéo
où on va regarder un petit peu
différents avis différents avis de
différents médias de personnes qui ont
pu tester la console deux longueurs
alors pas de la vidéo pas du blog parce
que ça prendrait beaucoup de temps et
que l'on n'a pas des heures non plus sur
une vidéo à regarder les avis des autres
pour ça tu as la playlist par contre ce
qui peut être vraiment bien on va les
regarder ensemble on va regarder
ensemble sur le web les différents avis
et puis comme ça va se faire une idée un
peu plus poussée de ce que pensent les
gens de ce que pensent les personnes qui
ont testé cette nintendo switch
maintenant qu'elle est sortie à lady
avec moi donc on va faire un tour du
côté de 01net.com qui a publié pas mal
d'articles sur la switch celui-ci de
clairefontaine est très intéressant
la nintendo succès une console portable
et ce n'est pas grave
merci c'est rassurant séduisante
intrigante la nouvelle console de
nintendo nous paraît avant tout être une
console portable ce qui est plutôt
positif tout bien pensée merci beaucoup
parce que je suis absolument d'accord
avec toi pierre fontaine qui est riche
absolument d'accord avec toi sur ce
parti qu'est ce exactement le point de
vue
fondée dans ma toute première vidéo sur
la switch alors on parle effectivement
du dock le fait que le doc n'intègre
aucune puce pour l'instant lui apportant
un véritable surplus de puissance prouve
bien son état naturel et dans la
mobilité
même s'il s'agit de rester vautré
plusieurs heures sur son canapé tablette
en main donc on est vraiment plus sur un
côté effectivement même si c'est même si
on est sur une console bride on est plus
sur un côté un peu plus portable ça on
le voit très bien alors bon là il ya un
côté très techniques sur la console on
s'en fout un petit peu un vieux rêve
réalisé mais il faut bien reconnaître
qu'on réalise enfin fantasme de joueurs
qu'on a défloré avec la wii au gamepad
c'était amusant de pouvoir jouer à
portée de la console maudite téléviseur
éteint c'est un plaisir incroyable de
quitter son salon où sa maison sans
abandonner pour autant son titre préféré
l'instant trépidant c'est très très
clair et on est vraiment dans cet esprit
là dans cet article c'est vraiment
d'expliquer en quoi la switch est
vraiment cette console hyper sympa et
très intéressante pour la porte ativités
penser la suite comme une console
portable que vous pouvez accrocher
parfois à votre téléviseur quand la
console bien plus séduisant voilà donc
elle échappe ainsi à la comparaison avec
les consoles de salon des générations
actuelles elle échappe ainsi à la
comparaison des consoles de salon des
générations actuelles bien plus
puissante qui offre des services bien
plus variées imaginez que la switch de
la 3ds qu'elle ne remplace
officiellement pas ne serait capable
on s'en fout donc voilà donc vous
explique aussi effectivement qu'on n'a
pas comparatif à toutes les consoles
actuelles à une playstation 3 ou une
xbox on est vraiment sur autre chose sur
un nouveau produit sur une nouvelle
création de produits qui est en train de
faire nintendo est a priori ce qui n'ont
pas investi avec la wiiu
là ils sont clairement en train
d'essayer de gravir un échelon
supplémentaire pour réussir avec cette
switch et ça c'est top
alors on continue ensuite saynètes test
l'intel de switcher trop emphatique
aussi vraiment intéressant parce qu'il
donne vraiment les plus et les moins
donc on va regarder les plus la
configuration hybride polyvalente qui
permet passer d'un écran de télévision
de téléviseurs à une console portable et
mende et joy code modulaire innovantes
l'ensemble bien pensée breach of the
wild est l'un des meilleurs jeux j'avais
proposé par nintendo pour un lancement
c'est vrai qu'il a connues supercritique
d'ailleurs j'en profitais dire qu'on dit
pour ce nouveau zelda bouysse of the
wild et pas breath of the white wolf
j'entends partout kita par thème est
allé préciser quand même aller les moins
en dehors de zelda pas de console
virtuelle et seulement une poignée de
titres
les fonctionnalités en ligne sont pour
le moment un mystère
l'écran un peu petit fectivement l'écran
est petit parce que si tu veux jouer sur
un écran partagé sur un mario kart
toi tu auras la partie du lot la partie
du bas ça reste quand même petit là ça
serait vraiment bien de jouer sur un
grand écran sur une télé parce que mario
kart amène à quel joueur tu imagines
actes et joy conne sur une toute petite
enfin deux joueurs qu'est ce que je dis
comme conneries à deux joueurs sur un
petit écran
tu va rapidement de faire mal aux yeux
les manettes sont étroites et encombrées
et celle de gauche pour rencontrer des
problèmes de connexion mode sans fil ça
c'est vrai que j'ai souvent vu sur le
son des vidéos youtube il ya des gens
qui se plaignent effectivement d'avoir
des problèmes de connexion alors on va
retomber faire un point mort après
l'article est sympa il présente vraiment
la console
graphiquement comment elle et les
finitions le port usb c'est donc à pas
mal de choses si tu veux aller voir
c'est pas mal lorsque nous aimons sur la
switch la polyvalence le fait de pouvoir
emmener cette console partout avec soi
est un pelé est vraiment plaisant le
système hybride fonctionne sans accroc
c'est génial le ca des spots à sion
réactive claire et permis de reprendre
un jean quelques secondes depuis la mode
veille le démarrage complet est lui-même
très rapide le multijoueur en local dcl
ayant pas pu la tester
car aucun jeux pan moment de le prendre
en charge le mode multijoueur de la
switch permet de connecter entre elles
jusqu à 8 tablettes ça ça peut être
vraiment sympa capture d'écran bon temps
des captures d'écran les animaux c'est
vrai que c'est sympa aussi voilà les
problèmes de la switch parce qu'il y en
a la ludothèque sortie de zelda c'est un
peu le désert
bah ouais cela devrait juste durer
jusqu'au moins la fin du premier
semestre il n'y a pas beaucoup de jeu
mais il ya là qui vont venir la console
wii d'ailleurs on disait il ya 60 jeux
qui ont été annoncées au moins un des
éditeurs indépendants dont il va y avoir
pas mal pas mal de choses que vous
n'avez plus les grands grande nouveauté
que nintendo a annoncé
donc il va y avoir effectivement tout un
catalogue qui va s'étoffer autour de ça
la console virtuelle voilà sont pas 3
pour le moment le deuil code gauche qui
se désynchronise il ya clairement un
problème avec cette manette que nous
l'avons
on peut le constater heureusement il ya
un correctif logiciel qui devrait régler
le souci
la taille de l'écran lorsqu'on utilise
en mode nomade l'écran de la console est
bon mais c'est une autre histoire lance
pour l'instant sur une table pour jouer
par exemple l'affichage des textes dans
zelda est si petit qu'il est difficile
de l'or de lire dès lors qu'on en est à
plus de 60 cm la béquille et ça j'avais
vu effectivement aussi sur la vidéo
justin que j'ai mis dans la playlist tu
peux aller voir la bête qu'il vole en
plastique qui casse le lecteur microsd
de la switch fait aussi office de
béquilles mais il est assez fin et
n'inspire pas confiance on eût aimé
qu'il est était qu'ils en aient une
seconde de notre côté pour l'équilibré
voilà donc pas d'audio sans fil pas de
bluetooth pour l'audio son fils le
retour des faits nintendo a peut-être un
peu trop promis avec le système de
retour des faits haptique eddie johnson
l'avant lisibilité en plein soleil bon
ça effectivement à l'extérieur quand il
ya plein de soleil même ses lacets
console est une très bonne luminosité
citant le soleil qui tape en direct au
dessus fatalement c'est la merde ça
c'est le problème de tous les écrans
donc voilà donc il te faut un petit peu
un petit topo
voilà voilà pour cette vue globale de
saynètes qui est vraiment très
intéressant tu peux aller voir cet
article aussi il est très sympa j'ai
trouvé aussi sans le journal du geek un
article intéressant notre compte rendu
complet de la console
moi ce qui m'intéressait là dessus c'est
un petit peu la vie final notre compte
rendu complet de la console donc voilà
il n'est pas pertinent de comparer la
switch avec d'autres machines
actuellement sur le marché
encore une fois avec ce système nintendo
joue sur un terrain différent de ses
principaux concurrents
après la promesse du constructeur de
proposer un système hybride ainsi à
l'aise dans la dans la portabilité que
dans ce salon est tenu avec brio et
permet une expérience de jeu
particulières en effet on ne boude pas
son plaisir d'arrêter de jouer dans
salon pour apporter sa console dans le
lit ou dehors sans interrompre sa partie
ça c'est ce que je te disais
ma toute première vidéo paf console
c'est ça le truc c'est qu'au final la
vidéo tu là partout tout le temps avec
toi et c'est génial on va les voir sur
le site ign.com que je ne connaissais
pas du tout après plus rien la console
hybride à l'art tradit le salon donc là
tu vois on est vraiment pareil
complètement d'accord la switch et la
vision du gaming
la suisse est la vision du gaming de
nintendo ne correspond pas à mon style
de jeu pc à sociale elles ont pourtant
une bonne complémentarité ce serait une
console idéale pour jouer en famille a
bien sûr si j'avais une suite chez moi
j'aime de police fribourgeoise est de
retour à lumbres est malade on est
d'accord effectivement pour moi le
moment de vérité ce n'est pas le mois de
lancement mais les fêtes de fin d'année
avec l'arrivée de super mario
odyssey ça je crois qu'effectivement
c'est clair une descente mais c'est kim
on attend ce jeu avec impatience
en tout cas le prix est honnête il n'est
pas question d'empêcher qui que ce soit
de se précipiter dessus
soyez juste prudent sur la manipulation
d'un switch en mode portable ça c'est
clair a pas été non plus contre les murs
exercice compliqué que conseiller
l'achat d'une console
erwan la switch entre site vraiment pas
la tâche après la prise en main le
hardware laisse tout d'abord assez
dubitatif avec avec une conception qui
me paraît à la fois un peu cheap
à l'image de la languette ça on en parle
encore cette fameuse langue est
permettant de poser la tablette sur une
tablette dont on ne donne pas cher de la
peau
effectivement on en parlait tout à
l'heure cette langue est elle espère pas
trop confiance malgré tout la sous
espèce dans l'ensemble une jolie console
portable pas trop lourde et dont l'écran
m'a offert de belles sensations de jeu
confortable et j'apprécie surtout que la
nouvelle machine de big band big n et
beaucoup de potentiel pour le gens
solitaires et pas qu'avec
party game ta différents points de vue
c'est vraiment intéressant tu vois enfin
je dois admettre que l'absence
d'applications comme netflix amazon
prime un navigateur et même tout
simplement twitch montrent bien un réel
manque de finition de la cour sol même
si l'os est rapide il est aussi simple
ici mais en 2017 ça ne se pose est gage
de qualité
oui effectivement c'est souvent
reprocher qu'il n'ya pas d'appli autres
youtube d'une éthique des choses comme
ça après je pense que il y aura
peut-être une mise à jour sans on verra
plus tard
toujours est il que nintendo a sorti une
console qui est de bonne facture très
bien fait donc on peut pas tout avoir
après effectivement on pourrait avoir
une console qui fait beaucoup de choses
je pense que l'on fait déjà pas mal pour
stella a proposé aujourd'hui allons voir
maintenant un petit peu plus loin est ce
que melty est chargée du côté de melty
une autre thèse d'une console presque
parfaite ça sent plutôt bon lors mail
ticket sur une cible plutôt jeune mais
c'est aussi très intéressant de voir ce
qu'ils en pensent
je le crie je pense parfaitement 4 août
est une console qui fait ce qu'on lui
demande d'une manière presque parfaite
c'est à dire donner la possibilité de
jouer en s'amusant sur d'excellents jeux
il ya eu la chance de jouer sur la
switch depuis environ une semaine depuis
une semaine environ avant la sortie
mondiale prévue en mars prochain ça va
saigner on va aller un petit peu vite un
concept simple mais unique et intuitif
voilà voilà pourquoi la switch avant
appelé mx est resté aussi ce crétin
console hybride
tu vois on est vraiment dans l'idée en
une part effectivement aussi de la
console hybride un design irréprochable
le design de la console n'est pas pour
rien avec un design de produits haut de
gamme la conception de la switch avec
les savamment étudiée pour pouvoir
effectuer de longues sessions de jeu
sans ressentir de fatigue et en
utilisant la modularité de ses
accessoires comme bon vous semble
de plus la switch est très légère est
incomparable avec ce qui se fait
habituellement sur les consoles de salon
en regardant la table et les domaines
manon va vraiment tu vois que on a des
retours positifs dans cette console la
console portable la plus puissante du
marché
donc effectivement part effectivement sa
puissance par rapport à ce qu'elle
propose un surnombre sur un côté
portables des nouveautés appréciables
les libration hd ça j'ai vu beaucoup
beaucoup d'idées
kiehl's et avait fallait vraiment laissé
pour se rendre compte des libration il
ya vraiment des déviations seront très
très fine et hyper précisant une
autonomie au poil
la promesse d'un bel avenir bon je te
passe un peu non pour moi les normes
points forts de la switch est également
sa capacité à rassembler à faire jouer
tout le monde dans une seule et même
pièce et donner le sourire dès
l'allumage brown ouais je pense vraiment
voilà c'est on est vraiment là dessus tu
pourras laisse nos blessures sertic de
meetic est très sympa aussi
alors là j'ai trouvé ce blog paradoxe
temporel point fr qui a un côté sur un
vieux wordpress un peu cheap mais la vie
aussi est très sympa donc tu as des
images effectivement un espèce de
knockin en photo de la console par
vraiment des vibrations l'hexagone sont
surprenants quand on n'utilise pas ce
qu'on peut ressentir des vibrations
c'est vraiment ce côté hd la vibration
extrêmement précise qu'est ce que
j'avais vu l'univers est grandiose donc
ça c'est pour zelda effectivement en one
to speech par exemple sont des petits
jeux qui ressemble plus à une démo cas
de vrais jeux et ce jeu aurait mis à
table et aurait mérité d'être gratuit ça
c'est discutable mais effectivement
dommage que cette console soit sorti
avec absolument aucun jeu au moment de
son lancement tâche est la console nu
coûte quand même un petit peu moins de
300 euros sans répit quand même bien
qu'ils aient un one to switch and hate
quitte à rajouter 10 20 euros bon tu
vois ça aurait pas été pas été inutile
donc voila un petit peu pour un tour
d'horizon et tout ce qu'on pouvait dire
sur la suite sera effectivement à cette
console elle est décriée par certains
par d'autres allaient encensé en tout
cas est vu comme une très bonne console
je pense qu'il y en a pour tout le monde
y en a pour tous les goûts donc
fatalement il ya toujours des gens qui
on pas et beaucoup notent qu'ils vont
l'adorer pour ma part je trouve
conseille vraiment super j'espère que
tous ses points de vue divers et variés
ont pu permettre d'affiner toi ta
compréhension et puis ton idée de la
switch la meilleure idée que tu puisses
ça bien sûr c'est d'essayer par toi mais
dans ce cas là soit tu peux aller c'est
directement dans un magasin soit acheter
soit rencontré quelqu'un qui l'a déjà
porte la faire essayer
merci en tout cas d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo n'hésite pas à regarder celle là
pour ta bonne et c'est par ici
merci beaucoup je t'embrasse quand je te
dis à très bien d'autres